we sell turkey fries okay and that's
turkey nuts so they're uh they're they
have glands and their nuts are actually
in their wings
no way yeah so they'll pop them things
out and you fry them up and eat them up
they good or bad they're good they're
really good yeah I mean did they bust a
little or they just kind of now they
just fry them up it's just like eating
uh eating it yeah like a what this is
like a nugget like a chicken nugget okay
you get you eat nuggets is this them
right here yeah
yeah they're good man I'm a big fan of
turkey I think it's a great meat it's
nourishing it's lean uh and I just
wondered why you don't see it on more
fast food chains like at McDonald's or
KFC because you know me I'd love to have
a gobble gobble why isn't it why isn't
turkey more that thing now you do see it
at like a Jimmy John's you do see it in
the Subways you see it at Arby's
um so you're seeing like uh a lot of
them it's gonna be like the sliced
turkey so that's something that we would
probably sell like a product where
they're getting that breast meat to the
masses I'd love to see like a a turkey
tender instead of a chicken tender
um I just think the market for it to be
sustainable like that the reason you
haven't seen the turkeys go hard
um it's just really just the we don't
have that type of uh
um that many farmers out there to
actually be able to consistently sustain
that that demand at the moment so it's
kind of like we go all in and then say
you guys don't end up wanting to you
know Turkey nuggets or whatnot and right
then then you got like a lot of farmers
don't invest it you know two three
million dollars in this stuff and then
they're out out on the streets again you
almost need a different height mate you
need like a big PR thing to be like
turkey is that thing it's like because
you see us at Panera Bread that's
another big comp oh yeah yeah
yeah it's interesting I hadn't really
thought like it's only turkey is often
sliced or you see it like a Boston
Market or something like that sometime a
place where they do more of a meal I
think yeah it's regarded as more of a
meal and not as much of a
I don't want to say like a cheap eat but
because I love turkey burgers turkey
burgers is something I love delicious
that's great man so
and maybe some of it's growing over time
do you know if the Market's growing over
time
um it has compared I mean you're going
from you know when my parents started in
89
yeah I know I know they've had some
attempts Niche markets where they
pushing it but now since people are more
want to know what they put in their body
like he was saying people want want that
lean protein from that turkey and it's
different than chicken yeah I think it's
if not better I mean you barbecue a
couple a couple chicken tenders and
slice that breast up just right I mean
it's good on the grill good good
anywhere man [ __ ] looks good man yeah
God damn it looks good yeah I'm thinking
about it right now dude if I had it I'd
cook it for you [ __ ] man
people see you they just want some damn
turkey like damn what are you doing here
give me something it's like yo man can I
get a get another slice I said no
problem
like you should just have it in your
coat like a little hit man you want some
breasts yeah
dude I'd probably take a little thigh
man I think you know Turkey fries you
wouldn't think that would be a nuts but
we sell a pile of turkey fries and what
is oh a turkey if I was enough nuts yeah
turkey nails but you haven't had that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one